welcome to another episode not too deep
I am your host grace and Helbig this
episode is fun
get ready strap in we have Natalie
Morales the star of Abby's the new NBC
sitcom on Thursday nights after Will and
Grace she is absolutely goddamn
delightful she is hilarious she tells us
about how she had hardcore gangster rap
dance parties and Amy Poehler's trailer
on the set of Parks and Rec she tells us
about how she had to audition as a
prostitute that got hit by a truck and
she tells us about the first commercial
she ever did where she tried to [ __ ] her
boyfriend for CBS it's a very colorful
flavorful episode and nothing that was a
lie it's all truth we learned all about
these stories on this episode of not too
deep with the wonderful Natalie Morales
not too deep is brought to you by
Squarespace turn your great idea into a
reality with Squarespace they make it
easier than ever to launch your passion
project whether you're showcasing your
work or selling products of any kind
with beautiful templates and the ability
to customize just about anything you can
easily make a beautiful website all by
yourself but if you do get stuck
Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support is there to help
head to squarespace.com slash Grace for
a free trial and when you are ready to
lunch use the offer code grace grac e to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain finally Natalie
Morales is here with us this is so
exciting thank you we're just talking
about how you're in the middle of a
whirlwind press junket tour oh yes
craziness what's been how long has this
been going for now um well the show
premieres tomorrow night so it's been
like this crazy push yeah so it's been a
while that it's been happening I would
say since like the beginning of the year
but like this last couple weeks has been
bananas for people that don't know
basically like when you do press for a
show it's like you're this marionette
puppet that gets brought around to a
bunch of different cameras and
microphones to talk ad nauseam about the
show and yourself and all these yeah
if so fact are you here talking yeah
yeah but I'm always curious because I've
done it and it is exhausting and it
becomes like I've felt myself become
like a hollow
version of myself where I'm just on
autopilot yeah even realizing yeah
what I'm talking about have you had any
standout ridiculous interviews or weird
turn around I mean I mean you've done
this a million yes sometimes I'll show
up somewhere for an interview like I did
some like like a serious interview once
where I showed up and the guy and I
don't mean like a like a like a funny
slash serious I mean like serious radio
very very dramatic no I did a serious
interview where where the guy was like
so what was it like hosting Miss
Universe and I was like I wouldn't know
because I didn't do that and he was like
what's it like faker on The Today Show
and I was like no idea he closes like
dossier on me uh not me I was like okay
let's talk about who you are that's you
so Natalie Morales is a you know another
woman that is thriving in media this on
The Today Show and has apparently hosted
the Miss Universe yes I guess one of
those miss like something well I did the
stupid thing yesterday I tweeted out
four questions for you and because
you're on Abby's on NBC and Natalie
Morales NBC is her Twitter handle so I
just assumed name NBC must have made you
update your Twitter handle to include
NBC I was like clearly this is her and
then like 30 seconds later I was like
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah disregard the time I'm sure I am a
solo writer on Twitter I had that first
I'm not proud to say it bit on there for
a decade it's not crazy I think I think
about when people pull up you know
problematic tweets from people in the
past I started to think well why I can't
have anything wrong on there because I
haven't been on there that long but no
it's been a decade yeah it's insane and
then I think about what the [ __ ] was I I
started a search like every bad horrible
word possible in my own Twitter and then
just to see I was like God did I ever
say anything terrible they have a night
really tied one on and let it loose it
was like oh okay yeah a nerd you hold
yourself to is like what actually has
happened yeah if the immature me that
was 23
yes Twitter its thought that she was
being really like insightful and but
turns out was probably problematic yeah
yeah the abbeys is coming out I'm so
excited it seems like a really [ __ ]
fun show the premise is almost like
backyard cheers in a way kind of yeah
yeah it's um it's a bunch of people
hanging out in a back yard in San Diego
at this illegal backyard bar and we shot
the whole thing outdoors oh you did with
inaudible yeah Melissa was sewing she
wish you a taping of it she said she
unfortunately saw the season finale so
yeah she did not care about anything
yeah it's yeah the whole thing was
outdoors which was well it's the first
day we were done that and it was really
fun because you actually you know when
you watch Sitka especially like a
multicam that has like you know sort of
a play set up in an audience things
start to feel a little bit fake you're
like yeah you see that a real street
that's not right that's astroturf that's
not right this was real there was like
you know birds chirpin and planes flying
and grass and we were like actually
outdoors so it's super cool feels it's
cool yeah but it also lends itself I
imagine to you guys as actors like
really feeling the vibe of this totally
like feeling like you're honest and
totally yeah they totally it was awesome
but you still the studio audience yes
yes that like I've never experienced
that no fun either been in the audience
or in front of the audience in that sort
of scenario yeah I mean I imagine it's
like if you do it for the first time
it's fun maybe for the next few times as
you are sure luckily wasn't as long as
most most tapings are we usually like
capped it at four hours but sometimes
like friends was like seven nine hour
tapings and they'd sometimes bring in
two audiences just to keep them for us
to keep them fresh because like imagine
you're hearing those
jokes aren't actors yeah it could
probably possibly get annoying but like
if you've never done that before you're
like maybe you're in LA for the first
time you go to Universal Studios you get
to see this taping that's like outdoors
it's it's fun and it's weird and and I
think the outdoor element is like kind
of has this feeling like anything could
happen
yeah and for us I mean I think all
everybody all the actors that were on
the show have some sort of experience
with an audience whether they do improv
or stand-up or [ __ ] or whatever like or
theater I did sketch in I did theater so
I love it when it's so fun to have an
audience there and you get immediate
feedback yeah whether something is
working or not which is nice and then
also you get to have fun and like some
people some people really turn on when
there's an audience like some actors
really like or like hams which is fun
it's like in real time totally yeah that
seems super fun did you okay the thing I
to me you're very much like this
Renaissance woman in media right now
sure you got it the I mean you've just
been working on so many different
projects and also you're immensely an
advocate and activist online for so many
different things that I was kind of like
this is so [ __ ] cool like you really
use your platform for good in a bunch of
different areas thank you rather than
like the [ __ ] narcissism that we all
indulge in kind of say hey where do you
I'm always curious for people that are
in media like where do you find or draw
the line between like speaking your
voice online versus like just posting
promotional stuff um I think that's a
super interesting question because I
don't know I I find it tiresome to just
be posting promotional stuff via and
honestly what's been really great about
Abbey's that even in this like insane
press whirlwind is that like I'm really
proud of it and I really like it and I
want people to see it right so it
doesn't get that tiring to talk about
because I want to be if there is
something that you're not like
embarrassed it's awesome yes so so it's
fun and I want to share stuff with
people that like I
genuinely sharing wit with them instead
of just promoting it but I am actively
promoting you know the show because I
wanted to do well and I want people to
see it for sure but yeah that line is is
interesting because I I started Twitter
like whoa
Twitter used to be was just jokes it
like comedy yeah and that's what I
really loved about it and and so then it
became not that in like 2015 yeah it
turned a corner it turned a real corner
and so I'm always sort of trying to get
it back there it doesn't quite work yeah
I don't know and then and then yeah
there is like there is a if you have
people that are like listening to what
you're saying and you want them to be
informed about stuff that's important so
like the two things that I I also don't
want to overwhelm myself or other people
sure and the two things that are
important to me like other than what I
do and my friends and my life are are
like gun violence prevention and animal
adoption those are like I mean obviously
other things are important to me but
they extremely worthy causes yeah you
can I got a hone it into something
instead of being all over the place
right you wear yourself thin on like
wanting every single outlet to be
supported right right then it does it
seems disingenuous and then doesn't work
anyway because you're just noise yeah
yeah so I try to like I work with these
two organizations really closely I I
work with every time for gun safety and
I work with best friends and then I just
hit those heart like I'd done like I
feel like also those are things that
everybody can get behind even though
every town thing because it's not
actually like a right wing left wing
thing it's like it's just about like
common sense no one's trying to take
your guns from you it's just like hey
obviously there's a problem opening and
like we should do something yeah um so
I'm just like those are again are the
things that I'm happy to talk about
because I'm like proud of the work that
we're doing yeah and also I think that
you present in an authentic way because
you genuinely care about it it's not
like you're an actress that's been asked
to promote this cause that you
know about or that you sort of care
about yeah it feels genuine to you
exactly and you know it's not worth it
if it doesn't feel that way totally do
you have people that you obsessively
follow on social media ooh interesting I
mean I'm a huge Britney Spears Instagram
fan Oh her Instagram is great I mean
talk about promoting causes she I she
doesn't do it she is she's delightful oh
she is she promotes my spirits as a
human and I look at her Instagram it is
so charming
oddly yes also like I don't understand
her sense of humor nope at all I kept on
like joke
this is great whatever it is whatever it
is I root for her yeah oh you're having
fun you seem happy yeah you have pain
range just a bunch of stripes I know no
you know it was really funny as Candice
Bergen
oh I don't follow she's amazing okay
she's very dry she's very fun I can't
wait I always need new recommendation
actually this is who I like to follow on
Twitter's is older people I love Carl
Reiner okay because they're like they
don't use it so you're like this is
amazing like Cher yes my favorite tweets
in like emoji hieroglyphics and I will
never fully understand it but I get like
60% of its so yes Diane Keaton is on
Instagram she is she posts outfits of
the day like by the way exactly the same
skirt with a hat and she's like this is
what I look like it's it's amazing I
can't I love it I have big plans this
afternoon like any of you scroll by it's
always like big black belt it's skirts
always it's so good I can't it's so
yeah I just started filing Tracee Ellis
Ross yes also great very inspiration is
so funny and also like she makes me feel
like I do absolutely nothing with my day
she's like up at 4:00 I am fully in the
gym doing all that but then she's like
on set just kind of singing to herself
and like in between scenes like you're
just having fun but I think about people
like that like I think about like I
don't know like you're Ryan Seacrest of
the world you like seem to have twins
you know that like a clone so we're in
the world yeah and I'm just like okay
maybe some people just like need more
stimulation than I do and like are
active all the time because I just like
know ya know is a lot I like to hermit
you do a lot you are like oh you do a
lot I I do a good job of making it seem
like I do I thank you because if you saw
my TV q of the amount of reality
television i watch behind the scenes it
is some might call it disgusting I think
it's respectable thank you
do you have guilty pleasures I mean now
that like do you watch a lot of TV I I
watch um I do watch some TV like I just
rewatched all of Game of Thrones again
oh okay he's a real nerd I watched it
with someone who had not seen it at all
so at least I had that excuse yeah man
yeah I like shows like killing Eve I'm
excited for obviously Bri oh my god what
did you watch I haven't finished the
whole thing yet it's just too soon
yeah I just got to I just got to the
girl who's like family abandoned her
because she was gay yeah it was a great
episode
they're selling their sauce no yeah
somewhat I talked about this with
someone and they said that their sauces
sold been sold out for like months you
know I don't have and I again like
Britney Spears root for them yeah but I
also felt like [ __ ] I should have got on
top of that as soon as I watch the
episode because
I want that sauce now so good I was like
it was like 1:00 a.m. after I'd finished
an episode and then you know how Netflix
just sort of rolls oh yeah thanks I was
like nope nope I'm turning no no that's
exactly yeah I was like okay it's up to
I'm staying the same thing they
delighted me I like a drug I was like
you have to stop after this because you
need to go to bed and like have a date
tomorrow yeah but what if I keep going
hmm because this is nourishing my soul
we're just kind of what sleep does to
sleep for this show I'll still feel good
tomorrow it doesn't work like that is
there one particular member of queer eye
that you're most obsessed with oh I
don't know you know that I
I just met a few of them last week and I
and I I had a little bit of a heart
attack yeah tell me okay like I was so
excited and then he was like what are
those it was like I don't know I mean I
turned around he like check the back of
it to see what they were notices staying
there and Antony passes binding goes out
tani how predictable and I was like this
is too much this is amazing so now I
feel like I have a cutpurse '''l
connection connection with tan and
Anthony and so I'm big fans of them so
much Tan has to know that his commentary
on any accessory or item of clothing
you're wearing carry such weight also by
the way I know Tan doesn't want it but
Tan can get it okay I'm gonna really
watch the seasons because he's never
touched the small of your back oh that's
true he's never checked the middle label
label my pants so that could be a
formative experience I'm so jealous
that's me yeah yeah
what okay so
in how long was the filming process for
Abbie's for this season we shot I think
we started in like August and then we
finished in November and finished in
November yeah we did ten episodes oh
dang what was the hardest thing about
that um not getting to do more obviously
yeah like we were all late schedule
wasn't like super easy but we did have
like we would do like three weeks on one
week off so we weren't sick none of us
were sick of it we were all like oh
that's great we could do more it was it
was really so fun man yeah we had the
best time that's how it was something
that I didn't know because people in
this town will be like oh my god you're
doing a multicam it's like the easiest
schedule in the biz it's so great you
just like get to do a table read and go
home well I imagine that if you're like
on Frasier on friends and then you're
going on four years yes it becomes a
well-oiled machine or you probably don't
need to rehearse as much you probably
have some cranky person on your cast
that is like I'm not doing this what I
heard was that like the friends cast
would do the table read like at the end
do the table read and then show up on
tape and I and be like like I know where
to sit at Central Park it'll be fine
yeah yeah which I get I totally get we
did not do that we rehearsed not crazy
hours but we would you know this is what
a week is like on we shot by the way we
shot it on Tuesday nights because
usually you would do you would shoot
your tape night on a Friday night but at
Universal Studios during the time that
we thought hat that we shot it had we
had we done it on a Friday night you
would have heard the screams from
Halloween Horror Nights oh yes so we had
to shift it when to Tuesday's when they
were dark I secretly wish that you never
shifted it ya know so we are it's like
you do a table read on am I on a
Wednesday okay and then you rehearse it
and then Thursday you rehearse all
morning and then you show it to the
studio and then they give notes and then
Friday based on that new script you do
it all rehearse it all day and then show
it to the network and then they give
notes and then Monday you block it all
out outdoors with the whole camp
makrooh you shoot anything that you that
is not in front of the audience meaning
like if there something indoors or
something at a different location and
then Tuesday again rehearse and block it
all day and then you do the show night
so you're performing the whole thing
every single day Wow so it is exhausting
yeah it is not as easy as everyone told
me this is basically you're doing like
small plays every day every single day
and then the thing is you have this
crazy big show night on a Tuesday they
need to wake up Wednesday morning to a
brand new script land a whole new play
the next week that's so intensive it's
intense but it's really fun I mean as
long as you're having a good yeah I'm
yeah that's the time way easier yeah
sure yeah I can imagine if there were
crotchety people on the cast then it
would make it no yeah this is awesome
the people of this guys are amazing
that's so cool so now it airs and then
you just basically wait to see if they
pick up us basically yeah I think they I
think hopefully we'll know and like May
and they it depends on like you know if
people actually watch it right now with
like network television it's either no
one watches that are like some people
watch it that's the craziest thing
unless here this is us I guess yeah yeah
I guess if you're I know that's it feels
like everyone throws spaghetti at a wall
network TV and they just see like who's
picking it off yeah yeah and it feels
like you could have a really great show
but people watch my not collagen in such
different ways now like you know Parks
and Rec is a beloved show and never it
was in danger being canceled every
single season no one watched it but then
it got on Netflix and then even more
people started watching it so I hope
that like that sort of translates
because it is a similar vibe because it
Mike shares our executive producer so
yeah you created that and the good place
and like executive producers at Brooklyn
nine-nine so I hope that those people
are like see this a though yeah see the
thing yeah cuz what's like the vibe and
tone is it similar to like Brooklyn
nine-nine and that's it's similar in
that like what I love about all Mike
share shows is that it's always this
like group of really well-defined really
specific characters who feel like you're
friends that you know hang out with you
feel like you're hanging out with them
when you're watching the show and that
is what I think our show has that's
similar to that that's cool and it feels
like the cast is so diverse that's like
you'll find someone that you relate to
or sound that you connect with Alia
garde
yeah let's super cool okay we're gonna
take a quick break when we get back we
have more questions for Natalie and then
your Instagram and Twitter questions
we'll be right back Oh get ready because
this episode of not too deep is brought
to you by third love with more than 70
sizes including their signature half cup
sizes third love designs bras with
breast size and shape in mind for a
perfect fit and premium feel just answer
a few simple questions via third loves
fit finder quiz to find your perfect fit
in 60 seconds then it thinks that their
loves 100% fit guarantee you can wear
wash and put your bra to the test for 60
days if you don't love it you can return
it and third level wash it and donate it
to a woman in need this is hands-down
the most comfortable bra comfortable bra
you'll ever own with straps that won't
slip tagless labels and lightweight
super thin memory foam cups I can attest
as a woman that eats breathe sleeps in
sports bras only this has been the most
comfortable actual bra company that
supports women that don't like actual
broth it just it's great it's very
comfortable hear it from me it's great
it's great third love knows there's a
perfect bra for everyone so right now
they're offering you beautiful listeners
15% off your first order go to third
love calm / grace now to find your
perfect fitting bra and get 15% off your
first purchase at third love.com / grace
for 15% off today we're back with
Natalie Morales okay you were I mean
what I'm sorry to do this cuz I hate
when people just read off my Wikipedia
page it's fine I didn't write it
sometimes all the stuff there is a wrong
they'll tell me if this is wrong the
video game MTV's pimp my ride I know
that is real that's real okay alright
character yeah one I didn't know the hem
TVs Tim I read had a video game yep it
goes for the PlayStation ok yeah what is
your character I think my character by
the way I didn't do the voice likeness
what aha they paid me like $200
the audition was at a hotel room it
sounds like it's gonna be bad it was
yeah it sounds stupid and then I like
they took a bunch of photos of like my
whole body for a whole day and then they
used that and they didn't even use your
voice oh they didn't use my voice have
you played the game I did rent it and I
played it when it came out I think you
can still rent it I think the
character's name is like Ayana or Anya
or something perfect ambiguously ethnic
like that that's hilarious
yeah and also what I mean what a
prestigious thing to have on your
resolutely which is me an exhibit also
the fact that I didn't do the voice is
so stupid it's like oddly degrading but
also like maybe for the last me like
really pixelated me like pink ah yeah
okay
how long have you been in entertainment
in total um I like I moved out here
because you were in you went you're from
Florida I'm from Miami yeah and then and
then me and my best friend moved out
here together okay and then and sort of
in the middle of that I lived in New
York and then I came back to LA but yeah
I mean I did like one CBS commercial in
Miami when I was like 18 in Spanish
where I played like a [ __ ] teenager
who you know I'm not kidding it was like
so the local Miami pharmacy was Eckert's
and CVS bought records it was like a
switch over and they were like now
that's like the the point of it was that
now that CVS is the pharmacy the wait
times are super short all right so I
like my mom's like I'm gonna go to the
pharmacy this is all in Spanish and I'm
like I call my brother like my mom's
gonna be gone forever
she's gone to the pharmacy so you should
come over and then my boyfriend rushes
over and of course my mom and him come
at the same time in a mark
yeah I did that's the beginning of my
illustrious entertainment career Wow
from that to pimp my ride the video yeah
yeah I mean okay I'm gonna test the
listeners with finding this commercial
oh my god guarantee it's bad that's so
funny okay so you've been in this whole
like quote game for a very long time
yeah I've been trying to do it
professionally since I was like 18 okay
yeah what do you have a standout or even
recent like worst auditioning story
that's I love to ask people that oh yes
I mean I know there's probably a billion
there's so many I would say the standout
one is early on I was auditioning to be
like a prostitute who got run over by a
car is this typecasting that they're
putting I know Tina and Preston I know
yep a sex worker I should say but in
this movie it was a definitely referred
to as a prostitute yeah run over by a
car yeah and so then in the audition
they were like okay like that was the I
was like how do i audition this I'd have
no lines oh wait so you didn't think my
only line was like ah how do you how do
you I did that so they require you to
dress so you had to go to your audition
drive to your audition dress like a fool
yeah what you a man is a prostitute
right like a like like you're selling
your body
yeah and then like when I was like what
do I do
they're like just stand stand against
the wall and then pretend something hits
you and then slide em in he was like he
was filming music unless I do it like
get fully on the floor and then he's
like and then the worst part of this is
that he was like that was great can you
stand up now and just dance to some
salsa and I was like oh why he's like
yeah cuz earlier we might have you
dancing to some salsa and I was like
okay and I stood there and he was like
what are you waiting for it I was like
oh is there
no music no music so I had to stand
there and be like I said no music and
thank you so much I did not get the part
[Applause]
but that doesn't stand out terrible
audition Wow yeah yeah that's specific I
had to park really far away to walk for
a long time oh god that's miserable and
also at that point I'd be like what
Ashton Kutcher prank show am I on I
wasn't happening I'm like you're putting
this on YouTube right like yeah that's
happening but that's one of those things
that you imagine like if you hit this if
you win some Academy Award that it gets
dug out of like the archives and someone
posts it I always think about who was it
on Punk'd that it was the meanest
frankly thought they were gonna be like
in a new spider-man and they were like
this is like a CGI thing where you're
playing like a dragon or something I
vaguely vaguely remember this but I
forget it was like literally what
Benedict Cumberbatch did you know but
but this was years I think it was like
Jesse Metcalfe or something I mean like
a CGI suit and we're like you have to be
this monster and it wasn't all a prank
and I was like this is I've stated my
heart it's like a deep fear yeah because
that show happened now that you're in
Hollywood it could happen anywhere also
any CG thing that you're doing is so
absurd like this is someone's filming
this this is stupid
yeah yeah this is for someone else not
me balls on me something it's not good
but anyone out there aspiring to become
Hollywood you know actress just known
that you pay your dues sometimes start
somewhere
did you act as a student I did do any
like student production I did I was
really bad I do not get cast in anything
I really I think I got pity cast in
California sweet when I was in high
school and then
and then in college I also was not never
cast in anything really never any of the
like theater you know mm-hmm thing I was
cussing like student stuff I didn't get
to do any of the big plays yeah cast me
anything that's okay it all worked out
yeah it's all working out now okay I saw
the video on your Instagram of you doing
karaoke and Oscars after-party yep
okay take us through this because you're
great wait was that from her show
because she knew the song yeah because
you also did this benefit comedy show
like variety show and I guess you also
yeah Melissa produced this this I did
this benefit show for March for our
lives yes September or August
Uncas I don't remember anyway one of the
things which I'm gonna put online
shortly because I have the footage I
just have to edit out perfect um was
that we had this amazing band and I was
like we also had like all these great
performers we had brude's perform we had
like all these awesome musicians and
like all these people did these songs
and then I 3/4 of the way the show I
come out and I'm like hey so I'm hosting
the show and it was also my idea so that
means I got to do what I wanna do is
sing you I don't know well my best
friend dances dude and so that's what we
did and it was absurd so cut to this
like super fancy Oscars party that like
Lady Gaga was that and like Mick Jagger
was that it was like it was like big
names and we were like me and my best
friend she was my date and and we were
there and we were like god this is crazy
we're just like staring at makjang
hospice Lucy and and and like
speculating about gaga
and Bradley Cooper that kind of party
and then I see a sign that says karaoke
it was in this other room
and I'm like what is that and we go in
and there's a band there
they're like live band karaoke and no
one is in there and there's
waiting for someone that yes like you
have for one very drunk woman who is
singing harp so horribly that the guy
playing pace is like he's like making
eye contact with man just like
interrupts this please come up and and
so I was like oh my god this is just
yeah this is dumb and then they only had
like a one sheet of paper like one of
saying this and that was one of them and
I was like well I know this song already
playing with a band so I was like I'll
do it I'm a drunk girl it's like I know
I don't
it's okay I don't need your help houses
do backup and the guy the bassist was
like it's okay ma'am please sit down and
so in the video that I posted on
Instagram you can hear her in the first
like a minute she goes oh my god me
you're so good that's her voice could be
good right no I she was so bad so yeah
it was just like we uh Sarina my best
friend and I love to go to fancy parties
and be absurd yeah that's my question
was like the few that I've been to are
always like so weird and awkward and
like multi-layer and stupid in so many
ways that you have to find the Sun it's
a favorite thing to do is to just go to
a weird party and be weird
yeah oh my god what's happening what can
we do and it's so fun to do that and and
just like get into weird situations
these are these reps this like
stuffiness I think is so necessary and
by the way me singing brought a ton of
people in and the thing to do at the
party hey guys hoping Mick Jagger would
come up but he did not you imagine my
god I would yeah
let's stick with the mouth god bless
um okay if you could intern for anybody
in the world who would you most want to
intern for oh that's a good question um
maybe like Tina Fey Oh that'd be cool
yeah I feel like I've learned a lot yeah
I feel like she'd be extremely wise yeah
extremely insightful and also like no
[ __ ] either and like hold you to a
standard but also still feel like sister
Lee yes yes I think it's a great answer
so it's March any ideas what you're
gonna be for Halloween you know I bet
everybody's gonna be this but I thought
what's your name Elizabeth the Holmes
thing that everyone I still haven't
watched it it's boring it's boring yeah
you get the point then like the first I
just an hour I've seen a billion
parodies of her voice is like very easy
to do yeah and like she was just like
really fakes her voice and talks like
this yeah is it so she definitely fakes
her voices it's just like no one has
that voice yeah a human yeah maybe Gigi
Hadid has that I was like drawing
compared but I think Gigi's is real I
think she just happens to have this deep
voice yeah I guess I've also never heard
Gigi Hadid speak and I was like it's
it's shocking but I you know she seems
to be doing great so it was just awkward
for her voice she's this woman's voice
it seems like she has a a deep voice but
she every time she does an interview she
like really play said I have this is a
power voice I've read this in a book and
this is how I talk in this I've talked
since I was seven years old
I feel like that's gonna change though
as far as my Halloween costume but for
now if Halloween was tomorrow yeah but
the thing is me and my best friend
Serena always do a couples costume oh
hell yeah or or like a group costume
last year we were Seinfeld and I was
George Costanza like a gold cap and all
this photo I was I was like I don't I
looked at it so quickly that I was like
I thought you were cool for a second
yeah I learned how to do a bald cap on
myself and I learned I mean kind of and
yeah and we've been like it's been great
we were we were as I said what are other
notable couples costume
we were Gallagher the comedian yeah and
other Gallagher his brother
I took over the business when he quit
and then they suit each other so I'm
just lucky but we were like who had
moustaches Oh another thing we try to do
we didn't do it with Seinfeld but we try
to do we try to be the the least sexy
sexy thing you can be yes we're we're
sexy Gallagher so we really uh we were
like you know short little shirts with
suspenders the Hat a mustache like a
watermelon purse the year before that we
were a sexy ZZ Top oh that's so gold
needs
that's so cool beards but just like a
bra under our thing boom guitars that I
had stuck a bunch of like cotton balls
to that's so yeah that's okay well you
guys still have time I think that's such
a good way to go solving okay well have
you ever did you do method acting at all
no no have you ever wanted to only the
only reason I think that that is valid
in any way is if you're doing an accent
because it's hard to keep it yeah so I
understand like if someone wants to stay
in an accent all day but like I read
somewhere that Bradley Cooper directed
directed drunk not actually drunk
playing drunk when he was in the scenes
but he was character star
yes for a stars born and he said that
it's like quoted something like it took
a lot longer to communicate to my career
I did how long the way and I was like
are you [ __ ] kidding me I can't
believe you you would be pretend to be
drunk while talking to your crew that
seems like it will be so frustrating for
everyone everyone you're costing
everyone like money time to direct them
normally take ten minutes get back into
it I don't know so no I don't really
believe in it in that way I think you're
just kind of being an [ __ ] yeah but I
don't know if whatever works for whoever
you know yeah if it's your thing and
it's gonna help you and it's an
experiment to do sure well that but I
think that the second you start
bothering other people it's sort of like
annoying is a little selfish yeah the
doodoo accent Saddam you know
yeah I know it's hard to like get into
and yes sometimes it depends on what it
is for sure for yeah directed a couple
episodes of mr. student body president I
didn't yeah is there something like
directing goals that you have in a few
totally yeah totally I love to direct I
directed room 104 which came out last
year I think I'm gonna do another one
which I'm really excited about cool
yeah just like ideally directing my own
stuff possibly us would be great
what's the most notable like notable
difficulty in directing versus acting in
you know it's a it's interesting to
think about cuz on any given day on a
set I mean generally I would say
directing is harder but it depends on
the role and what you're doing show on
any given day on a set one or the other
could be harder like for example i when
i was doing room 104 i was sitting there
and katie do plus had to do just tons of
monologues and i was like I do not envy
you man like and we only had two takes
and like she knows she had to get it in
that time yeah and I I was like I I
would hate to be you right yeah yeah
yeah right but then there are other
times where I'm not doing anything and
the directors trying to figure out a
million other things in his head or her
head and and that's harder so it's just
that kind of depends on it depends on
the print like the day and the
production yeah yeah have you what was
it like directing mister student body
president cuz that process are cool oh
yeah you're fine that show was great I
thought it was so smart and so fun and
everybody that was working on that show
from the crew to the actors were so good
yeah yeah so good yeah that I I was kind
of shocked by it
I had a were you not shock quality I
wish at this obviously we're shocked at
the actors like I came on for like a day
or two and like just they're very young
but they're super so good that's that's
what I was like oh man everybody is like
so good the thing is what I mean by it
is that you don't think like you don't
always assume like a lower budget show
that's right like go 90 is gonna be run
well with great producers great actors
and a great crew like you don't think
that that goes the other way so yeah it
was awesome to work on it was really
great yeah yeah yeah um what's been the
hardest I have you directed [ __ ] like
children children before um I don't
think I have in that oh no I don't think
I have like little kids yeah yeah I just
imagine that they're awful I just wanted
to hear someone tell me the children are
all they have they have a reputation and
it's hard to work with is there a
youtube clip that you would rewatch over
and over again
do you watch anything to like inspire
you motivate you a sale cat oh my god
yeah that inspires me and motivates me
you have a cat perfectly timed to that
song whoever figured that out it is
genius keeps getting fire it's so
wonderful and then it's like just a true
sign of internet being internet that
it's like this someone saw this clip
someone had some recollection of like
this kind of could fit to this song let
me see it's and then what it's amazing
and it brings us nothing but joy what's
coming up for me yeah well Abbie's
there's a there's a few episodes of that
and then in the summer I did this movie
called stupor with Kumail Nanjiani and
Dave Bautista cool I'm so I'm really
excited about that that's awesome what's
the premise of that Stuber is called
that because Kumail plays an uber driver
named Stu plays my dad and they say like
hard-edged
cop you know you know who gets LASIK
surgery and the same day that he gets
that gets a huge lead on a case and he
can't drive and no one's letting him
like his the people at his office are
like relax take a day off he refuses to
so he hires an uber and basically
kidnaps him
it's just that a big action crazy
adventure that sounds super fun it's
very fun when did you guys shoot that we
shot in Anna in Atlanta last year last
summer oh sweet yeah is it mostly take
place in the car not mostly they
certainly do get out of the car but yes
there is a hard time I don't think it's
in any way sponsored by uber they are
because it's like public domain domain
at this point I guess but yeah it's uh I
can't wait where is that be are we
allowed to know where it's like this
episode won't come out to next week two
weeks about two weeks
yeah so we're like maybe midway through
Abby's okay right yeah and then Thursday
night's 9:30 and then and then that I
think comes out in like July sweet yeah
ok cool we're gonna take one more break
and then we're gonna get into all of
these Instagram and Twitter questions
because inquiring minds have a lot they
want to know we'll be right back with
more not too deep too deep is brought to
you by square space square space makes
it easier than ever to launch your
passion project whether you're looking
to start a new business showcase your
work published content sell products and
more Squarespace is the tool for you
with beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks you can easily make a beautiful
website all by yourself plus they had a
powerful ecommerce functionality that
lets you sell anything online and
analytics I'll help you grow your site
in real time
everything is optimized for mobile right
on the box and there's nothing to patch
or upgrade ever buying domains is simple
and you'll get the help you need with
Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support they empower millions
of people from designers to lawyers
artists gamers even restaurants and gyms
to turn their great ideas into something
real so head to squarespace.com slash
Grace for a free trial and when you are
ready to launch use the offer code grace
to save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain that squarespace.com
slash grace offer code grace
2deep 2deep is brought you by threat up
did you know fashion is the second most
polluting industry in the world I
honestly did not and that's why I love
shopping second hand at thredUP thought
up is the world's largest online
consignment and thrift store with up to
90 percent off
estimated retail price they add over
50,000 new items every day at unbeatable
prices shop all your favorite brands
right from the comfort of your couch
made well from $9 anthropology from $13
Nike from $6 what everything is hand
inspected and triple checked I'm not
talking about single double I'm talking
triple check to ensure it's in the high
quality condition never pay full price
again and shop guilt-free at thredUP
this company is wonderful and this is
the easiest to use website and it saves
you money so what are you waiting for
thread up is offering not too deep
wonderful listening humans a limited
time special offer you an extra 30% off
your first order if you've is up if
you've is up sorry I'm so excited about
this that I can't speak words up thread
up.com
slash grace that's t h re d you p.com
such grace for 30% off your first order
no a in there just when I myself Philly
my ace so just make sure there's no a in
there that's thread up dot-com slash
grace for an extra 30% off today terms
apply okay okay okay here before we get
into these twitter and instagram
questions I'm gonna ask you the two
questions asked every single guest
that's on the podcast and the first is
who alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti at oh I mean does
everybody answer Hitler a lot of people
answer Hitler oh we had a lot of trumps
and Hitler's I'll say Fidel Castro oh
okay I'd be different okay the other
question I ask every guest is to tell us
your worst pants [ __ ] story or like
a close call but you can only use three
words or three small phrases so mine is
college jogging front lawn interesting
huh I can also be like a pissed your
pants scenario scenario sort of
embarrassing bodily fluids yeah and or
solid situations you know depending on
healthy you are gay I have a solid one
but all right let me think three words
hmm party both ends okay someone's know
what app are you most embarrassed that
you use no um I don't know that I am
embarrassed by stuff I don't really
believe in the whole guilty pleasures
sure like it's a pleasure want to be a
pleasure for sure guilty that's the
philosophy of taking on I watch too much
reality television and I used to be like
the answer to that is I play puzzle
games okay that are probably for
children or for like moms you have a
favorite of their children I do what's a
comes out I'm out get them to sponsor
this episode I left my phone over there
like a pro see oh my god way too much of
this and by way too much I mean I'm on
level like 1000 panda base game I don't
know how they keep innovating past level
1000 it is it is really great and I and
I play it a lot I think that's good
though I only started playing because I
had to get away from cookie Jam all by
the same company jam city games we make
great games they know what they're doing
yeah yeah that's so funny I don't think
that's the worst thing you could waste
your time doing what's happening let me
out of that okay um someone oh what's
the worst movie you've ever watched oh
that's a hard question yeah I feel like
I walked out of the postman oh yeah
but I don't remember it really I just
remember being [ __ ] he's remember your
feelings like oh I was also really young
I don't know there you go it might be
great and I missed it like I might have
missed the point but more likely than
not it's just bad okay yeah someone to
know what's your ideal date whoa
ideal date
I like doing something I've never done
before oh that's close always nice yeah
memorable but if that's not possible
I like an escape room oh really real
tests you love escape the other person
cuz like hey you have to see me in that
situation which is like intense and
problem-solving and you have to still
like me and B I have to see if you're
like you know you can communicate and
keep up I think that's a good ok it's
also I think dates with activities are
always yeah pretty solid yeah um I like
that I like the idea of like playing a
game what's been the best escape room
that you've done well the last one I did
oh my god I've never done one oh my god
they're so fun i I've dumped so many I
just did one called red giant that's
like a whole Indiana Jones themed one oh
that's great very pl was there want you
but terrible one well that one was also
terrible and here's why not because of
the actual game I accidentally ate a
weed mint that was four times the
strength note that I should take no no
um because I thought it was an
antibiotic I so I flew like cross the
ocean to Finland right and I was like oh
my god I'm flying I'm gonna be in coach
on this like 12-hour flight I'm gonna
die this is gonna be horrible I need to
be passed out for the whole time so I
got these weed mints yeah and I was like
I'll just put them in an old
prescription bottle and I'll and that'll
be great and so then I mixed up the
prescription bottle and I took it before
dinner and then like halfway through I
was like and then I had to do an escape
room that was really well done but like
therefore very scary to me because they
were like okay good luck and then they
lock this in a room and turned off the
light no no no and I had to dig through
bone
for clues and then yeah and then at one
point the walls start closing in on you
and you have to say actually yes and so
if there was like CCTV of that you would
see me like every five minutes or so be
like because I kept thinking something
was coming after me and I still made it
I still got out of the room but I was
not myself so that was really great and
it was also terrible for me
Wow I was very scared what truly like
I've never been so scared that I shiver
that gives me anxiety does here just you
know like most escape rooms if you get
you yeah you didn't let go to the
bathroom and come back you can it's not
locked in there that's what people's
fear is and you have that fear - it's
not like that was my my original kind of
like dismissal of escape rooms because I
get really claustrophobic yeah so I
don't assume that it was just like
you're in a tiny little no not all the
time it's not really like I think if
there's an activity that my brain can
focus on that's a little less stressful
very fun but that is so funny yeah I one
time like mistook like a Tylenol for
like a xanax before hanging out with a
friend and thank God like I like
dilly-dallied before leaving my house
cuz all of a sudden I was just like
would it's happening the walls are
moving now like now I just need to sit
in my bed I can't go out god no I found
out in public right as we were like
heading to the escape room I was like oh
someone oh what's one message that you
want everyone to get from your new show
oh that's a good question
um not message necessarily but I'd like
you to have fun I'd like you to enjoy
yourself and I'd like it to feel like
you're hanging out with your friends oh
nice yeah um someone wants to know are
you doing insta lives again I've never
really done them this person might be
confusing you with Natalie Morales maybe
I
Prison says I love it when she chats
with us one time she gave me fantastic
advice it didn't go my way but her
advice gave me courage I do remember
that oh you do okay okay so this is you
okay give you courage I'm sorry I didn't
work out I just don't do them a lot I
think I do them when I'm bored but yeah
I haven't done one in months so maybe
I'll do one again at another point when
I'm bored and maybe you'll be on there
at the same time there you go yeah
what's your favorite social media
platform to use do you have one you know
that's a hard question because I hate
them I hate them all I only am on
Instagram and Twitter and and I they're
both good and they're both bad right
yeah like I guess Instagram is a little
better because you can delete comments
oh and you can block comments you can
also do that on Twitter you can I hear
you can mute you can mute but then
they're still there yeah fair you can
also mute words like specific you can
still write them and they still show up
on Instagram if you say something shitty
I delete you're a serial you're a gun
yeah blocked and your comment was never
there it's wonderful yeah it never
existed yeah you get to play God on your
own feet and you should be able to do
that on your own stuff like shoes shitty
things on my exactly yeah yeah I'm
someone to know what's the where's the
weirdest place you've thrown up oh um at
a party cuz someone my friend showed me
a friend showed me a picture of oysters
with cheese on them I he was like I just
went to New Orleans look at all this
great food I ate and I think he showed
me that oysters and I was like what's on
those and he's like it's melted cheese
and I was like I literally went to the
bathroom and barf to come a picture just
from a photo of oysters with cheese the
concept of disgusted me yeah that's a
weird
that's a weird bar that is I was already
sort of pre nauseous because I had taken
a lift to the party and I get motion
sorry yeah like it was yeah it was like
there
really pushed me over the edge yeah
that's very funny a lot of people are
asking about santa clarita diet
do you paint in real life oh that's
funny I don't paint as good as an Garcia
does I want those paintings I keep
asking them for them but everyone's
asking about your time on santa clarita
diets yeah it's awesome it's such a fun
set to work on I've worked with Tim
before Tim played my boyfriend on the
grinder as himself amazing yeah it was
so great and then Drew and I did this
movie called going the distance that's a
great movie so we had already worked
together and then Mary Elizabeth Ellis
was also on the grinder and it's like a
familiar familiar and it's really really
fun to get to work with them again and
the new season comes up the day after a
beast oh really oh yeah oh yeah don't
like me stay away from your talk
someone's no strangest telemarketer or
attempted scam Oh have you ever had an
attempted scam I think I've had like you
know the same thing we've all had where
someone's like I'm stranded in some
weird country please send me money you
know it comes from an email of someone
you know
oh I don't never had oh yeah like it'll
come from an email like they'll hack the
email of someone you know and then it'll
be like you like it'll be like grace
says like I'm stuck how can you wire me
or send me right here the only email I
could find I'm so yeah I was being
kidnapped some horrible thing and then
you're like oh my god I didn't know
about that - yeah that's a real that's a
real thing oh [ __ ] I didn't like if my
mom got that she'd immediately sent me
she'd be like here's everything fine
I'll just get my mom that does not give
you ideas yeah so let's know what would
her illegal backyard bar be called and
why my illegal backyard bar would be
like no one comes I don't want people in
my house everyone only my friends come
only friend yeah you stay away I like
people in my house
strange people no she was awful someone
to know what's been your favorite show
to be a part of so far oh that's a hard
question cuz I'm sure they're all
different for different reasons yeah and
they're and I've been really lucky to be
a part of like really great stuff like
Parks and Rec was my favorite show right
before I was on it and after I was on it
after I did it
that must've been intimidating to go to
that sadly I was everyday I was like
[Laughter]
totally intimidating but in the best way
where I was just like I'm in the
presence of greatness yeah and I must
live up to this challenge yeah it really
was exciting for me how would ya how was
that experience it was so awesome I mean
and they were so welcoming especially
Amy like Jamie would have every day
after lunch she'd have a dance party in
the trailer to like disgusting gangsta
rap just hardcore thanks Rob and she'd
just be like it was necessary it was
like part of the day yeah it was like we
need to have this dance party and she
like looked at me once it was like the
songs for you and then we danced in the
trailer and I was like I think I could
videotape this and put it in my heart a
lot of people doesn't want to know what
is the best what is the best reaction to
walking into a glass wall oh I think
this is a person that asked it multiple
multiple times but I don't know if he's
asking what's the best reaction if
someone else walks into a glass wall or
if you walk into a glass wall which
isn't like a sliding glass door I would
I would say we're window you don't call
it a glass wall yeah very specifically
weird question I would say what's the
best way to recover from walking into a
sliding glass door or a window I you
said you've done this yes when I was
like 11 or 12 at my little cousins
baptism huh it was a party afterwards
and I was running around playing
and I and I ran like ran into the
sliding glass door and passed out then
when I woke up everybody was around me
but also my entire dress had come no one
thought to put it down I don't know why
and so don't look around you and make
sure your clothes are on you I guess I
think that's so fair for any age yeah
someone's no favorite dog and or cat or
other animals do you follow like
Instagram animals yes there's oh there's
this delightful little dog named I think
her her Instagram name is Holly's
amazing journey a purr and I can I I'm
gonna pull it outta so you can see it
because there's also called Josh I think
Josh the doodle is amazing
josh has like a some sort of
neurological disorder where he can't
really walk by he's really excited it's
amazing okay hold on I gotta find this
cuz you're gonna die I can't wait but I
always need new recommendations on
animal instead Holly
Holly's amazing journey I am obsessed
with her this is what she looks like oh
my god
what that's an ostrich yes she's a
beautiful ostrich baby that's a dog it
is a dog oh my god it looks like a tiny
hairless Chihuahua ostrich she does
she's just this and she's very sassy and
oh really fantastic and they love her
she's like a hairless Chihuahua she's I
think she's like a Chinese Crested yeah
like a chola oh my gosh this is like
Tilda Swinton as a dog yes exactly that
she's wonderful that she brings me a lot
of joy Holly's amazing journey
Holly's amazing journey oh look at that
little thing
look at the fragile little beautiful
thing a sweet sweet wreck yes
are your animals on no no or not okay
sometimes join me on my sand photos yeah
not on they don't have their own you
haven't done the independent accentuate
take the rejection I would be so mad so
I just don't subject them to me being a
stage mom I think that's a very healthy
motherly point of view yeah those things
okay we've reached the end of the
podcast as a but before we're completely
done I wanted to give you the gift that
every guest on the podcast gets it's a
personalized fortune cookie I love for
just for you you can open in Scituate or
something like ASMR and hell yeah this
is a little bit yeah it's not there we
go we got there we got a my to read it
out loud and I believe so okay oh my god
this is alone its fortune cookies that
are like not a fortune yeah that are
more of like a demand or just like like
you're a good person yeah the sun's out
today this is [ __ ] I don't know what
happens although when I first I have it
framed somewhere when I first moved to
LA I had a I got a fortune cookie that
said you will succeed in the field of
entertainment it was like oh my god and
then I realize it must be every fortune
cookie keep going back to that
restaurant okay some people might be
confused and tune in to your show hoping
for that Abby Lee Miller biopic biopic
series I always say biopic look I never
know how to pronounce it
it's a biographical picture yeah I was
told okay oh sure when someone corrected
me biopic series but will pleasantly
well will pleasant okay I'm gonna read
what's wrong yeah we might have type up
biopic series but we'll pleasantly
surprised by the twist enjoying the
humor but for real though where that
Abby Lee Miller show up who is Abby Lee
Miller oh she is um another powerful
woman in entertainment
she is the woman that runs Dance Moms
that reality television show she went to
jail she have made it some taxes she's
back she's gonna do yeah she got studio
in Santa Monica you need to do that off
you want player nope I don't think I
have the range and acting ability to
play to say the least
I just want to point out that there's
zero crunch in this no yes you should
have eaten it that's how you want to
describe a fortune cookie you're acting
commitment you are rock solid no crunch
okay Natalie where can people find the
show where can they find you and
everything that you're up to
Abby's is on NBC 9:30 p.m. after Will &
Grace on Thursday hell yeah I'm on
Twitter at Natalie Morales and on
Instagram at Natalie Morales loves
because it used to be Natalie Morales
loves free stuff and I decided that was
too materialistic open it up broaden the
spectrum and don't get her confused with
the Nana Morales that is host on The
Today Show no and make sure you check
out Abby's it looks amazing you're
amazing thank you for making time and
we'll see you guys next time an episode
of not too deep goodbye too deep deep
deep deep this episode is brought to you
by thredUP want to save money save the
planet and look good doing it it doesn't
get any better than thredUP the largest
online consignment and thrift store shop
over 35,000 brands at up to 90% off
estimated retail go to thredUP calm
slash grace for an extra 30% off your
first order that's T H or D you Pete
calm slash grac
thread up that calm such grace for an
extra 30% off today not too deep is a
production of grace helbig incorporated
producer and edited by melissa demons
writing by Diane Kang at post-production
sound by Christopher bell and an extra
special thanks to flu
for the theme music
[Music]